we are the most self-centered generation
in history not just the the generation
that exists but the baby boom generation
before it was brought up on the mean
generation and everything in society
teaches it's all about me every
commercial says it's all about you we do
it all for you have it your way you
deserve it
I've got to think of me first and we are
taught selfishness and that's why when I
wrote Purpose Driven Life it's really a
countercultural book because the very
first sentence is the exact opposite of
our culture it says it's not about you
and that's almost like a slap in the
face no I'm sorry it's not about you
there are a lot of things bigger in the
world that's simply your own happiness
your own fulfillment your own little
selfish claw of a life is George Bernard
Bernard Shaw called it and the the the
reason we have high divorce is people
don't haven't been given good models
their parents often weren't a good model
of unselfishness second I think it takes
three to make a marriage work
I think it takes you I think it takes
your spouse and I think it takes God
it's like a three you can't have a two
legged stool it'll fall over one legged
stool will fall over two legged stool
but when you have you yourself and your
partner and God in the thing it makes a
triangle and as you're growing closer to
God and your spouse of growing closer to
God it automatically brings you together
my wife and I as I said are extremely
different from each other in practically
every single way but as we grow closer
to God we grow closer to each other and
it is the glue that has held us together
when every bone in my body wanted to
give up or in her body now we actually
made a commitment when you know it was
till death do us part and so we said
we're gonna lock this gay patch close it
and throw away the key now in those
first two years when it was hell on
earth I mean really we started fighting
on the on the honeymoon and we were
going wait a minute I saved myself for
this it was like what a disappointment
you know
and and we you know we were fighting
from the first day on because we were
immature and we didn't know how how to
share now to learn but as you grow
through life if you stay with a
commitment it really will get better
it's it's being willing to learn being
willing to reconcile work don't fix the
blame fix the problem